- Welcome back for those of you
who've been here before.
Welcome to the next
installment of this series
at the Whitney Humanity
Center at Yale called
The Value of Marx's "Capital",
a little bit tongue in cheek,
but we're trying to think
about the new values that can be produced
by reading it differently
and reading it today
with some of the most
interesting interpreters
of the text of the moment.
These are the Franke
Lectures in the Humanities.
The series is a companion
to an undergraduate seminar at Yale.
Can you all just give me a
thumbs up if you can hear me?
Okay, good. Thank you.
Got nervous there for a minute.
And it's also goes
along with the work that my collaborator,
Paul Reitter at OSU, is
doing on a new translation
of volume one into English,
which I am co-editing with him.
That should be out we
hope in our lifetimes.
I need to thank first of all
the Franke family who make possible
the Franke Lectures, that's
Richard and Barbara Franke.
These lectures are intended
to present important topics
in the humanities to a
wide and general audience.
I'd like to thank Alice Kaplan,
the director of the
Whitney Humanity Center
who is already doing
brilliant things beginning
in her first term.
Sandra Malan-Bowles, who's an
administrator at the Whitney,
who's organized everything.
On the backend, Leana Hirshfeld-Kroan,
who's our graduate assistant
who's organized everything
on the front end.
And Audrey Leake, who is
our undergraduate assistant
running the show, the technological show.
We're going to do what we always do
which is have a presentation.
And after that, we'll take questions.
I'm gonna ask you to keep your questions,
note them down, and then to put them
in the chat after I give
the signal and we'll go
through them one by one, as
they're relevant to the talk.
Don't post your questions
now because they'll get lost.
I like to start with a quotation
from a work by our author.
And here I'm going to quote
from the introduction to a book edited
by Tithi Bhattacharya, "Social
Reproduction Theory" in 2017,
quote, "If as we propose the special
separation between production, public,
and reproduction, private,
is a historical form of appearance
then the labor that is dispensed
in both spheres must also
be theorized integratively."
I take this to be a kind of a motto
and a project that she has been
carrying out for many years.
And I'd like to introduce her,
Professor Tithi Bhattacharya
is a professor of South Asian history
and Director of Global
Studies at Purdue University.
She's the author of "The
Sentinels of Culture,
Class Education and the
Colonial Intellectual in Bengal"
from 2005 and has been
a long-time activist
for Palestinian Justice.
She's a type of person who brings
her intellectual work
together with her work
as a social justice activist
in the most admirable way,
locally, across the world, with students.
So I'm really very happy that she's here.
She's written extensively
on Marxist theory, on gender,
and her work has been published
in the Journal of Asian
Studies, South Asia Research.
And she is one of the authors of
"Feminism For the 99%",
along with Cincia Arutsa,
who's gonna be here at
the end of this series,
and Nancy Frazier.
I'd like all of us to, if
we can virtually applaud
and welcome Tithi
Bhattacharya to this series.
Welcome.
- Thank you, Paul, for that very,
very generous introduction.
I also have a few thank
yous before I start.
Thank you, Paul North and Paul Reitter
for inviting me to this brilliant project
of sort of discussing
the "Capital Volume 1"
at a moment of real crisis in our world
and discussing it with not just
the general public,
but also very crucially
with undergraduates in the university.
So thank you.
I also want to thank Leana
and Audrey for helping
me with the presentation
and thank you to all of
you who are tuning in.
And I look forward to engaging
with you on this issue.
This is a very important seminar series
and a very unique one
because I had the good
fortune to actually hear
the previous speakers at the seminar.
And it's unique
because usually when I speak
about "Capital Volume I"
or Marxist theory in general,
I have to spend a lot of time introducing
what Social Reproduction Theory is.
In this seminar, my colleague and comrade,
Lucia Pradella has already introduced
Social Reproduction Theory before my talk.
So I'm very grateful
that this has already been a live category
of engagement and conversation.
So I'm going to start with,
I'm sorry.
There was something
- Do you want me to put up
your slide presentation.
Are we at that moment?
- No, Sorry.
It's not somehow,
my file is not opening properly.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
Okay, it is now.
So capital for most of
you who have engaged
with the text quite
extensively already know
that it is of course
about the working class
and hence it is about labor,
but this claim can appear
a bit controversial
because barring a few passages
and the very famous
chapter on the working day,
"Capital" as a text is actually
predominantly concerned
with abstract labor or
the value form of labor.
So what do I mean about
the value form of labor?
Meaning that the text talks not so much
about work or labor,
except that famous chapter,
but about labor power,
the capacity to labor,
which is what the worker
is forced to sell to the capitalist.
And the text also spends
a lot of time discussing
how that labor power through
a rather torturous process turns
into surplus value or profit.
But since it is capital
that best teaches us that
the value form violates
and extinguishes all sensuous
properties of human labor,
Marx' central concern
in Capital appears to be
tracing the procedures
of that extinguishment rather
than establishing the subjective
conscious aspects of human labor.
This particular reading of "Capital"
as a text organized
solely around the formed
determination of wage
labor has actually led
some Marxists to make a
further analytical leap
about the indifference if you like
of capitalism as a mode of production.
So for instance, Ellen Meiksins Wood,
a prominent advocate of
this view has argued,
Audrey, could we have
the first slide please?
Thank you.
So it's the next slide.
So Ellen Wood has argued that sexual
and racial equality are not
in principle incompatible with capitalism.
The disappearance of class
inequality on the other hand
is by definition
incompatible with capitalism.
So in other words
we can have a capitalism where there is
no sexual or racial inequality inequality
but we can't have a capitalism
where there's class equality.
In this reading of Marx,
capitalism as a system is reconstructed
as the first and only exploitive system
that does not require the production
and sustenance of extra
economic inequalities.
The existence of such inequalities is seen
as contingent rather than exigent
to the system whose reproduction
can be assured simply
through the wage form or
through the extraction
of surplus value between
economically unequal
but juridically equal subjects.
Social Reproduction Theory,
a conceptual operator's
primarily developed
from "Capital" by Marxist feminists.
I will argue today offers a reading
of capitalism and of "Capital Volume I".
One that is actually more consistent
with Marx's own method
than this hypothesis
of capitalist indifference.
Next slide please.
So I'd make this argument
in three separate, but related ways.
First at a general level, by
looking at the status of labor
in "Capital" a second, through
a more specific argument
about capitalism, systemic unity,
and this sort of hearkens
back to the quote
that Paul used from my essay earlier.
And finally through an empirical argument
about how it is exactly that labor
power is differentiated
dividing the working class
into distinct sectors.
So let me preface my argument
with some very brief remarks
about Social Reproduction Theory, or SRT,
and its theoretical contours.
Fundamentally SRT theorizes labor power,
and the practices that
enable its reproduction
within capitalist social relations,
situated within and following
from the conceptual
architecture of "Capital",
SRT proposes that, next slide please.
One, the labor expended
in the production of
commodities that is at the point
of production and the labor
expended for the production
of people or workers who produce
such commodities are part
of the same capitalist totality
and together constitutive of value.
And the second proposal is
that the working class
family is the primary
but not the only site
for the reproduction of labor
power or the reproduction
of the working class as a whole.
Further, SRT identifies
capital's contradictory relationship
to labor power as a key
feature of the system.
How is it contradictory?
Because on the one hand,
capital needs a steady predictable circuit
for the reproduction of labor
power, since it is the source
of capitalist profit and
hence its own reproduction.
So it has to have reliable means
that labor power is reproduced constantly,
but on the other hand,
that labor power is actually reproduced
by human beings and hence
how it is reproduced
to what extent labor powers
capacities are developed
or the human capacities are developed
may not always align with capital's needs
thus all sites and processes
for the reproduction
of labor power are ultimately arenas
of contestation between labor and capital.
The former constantly
tending towards greater share
of civilization to develop
and further human capacities.
So that's labor's job,
while the latter, i.e., capital,
straining to reduce such a share
and mold labor power, and
such capacities to create
and maintain the productive
worker that capital needs.
So let's look at some examples, right?
So think about what kind of
a worker capitalism needs
and how do we attain it.
So in that sense you have
great to discipline at schools to produce
the perfect subject for
work later on in life.
You have the heteronormative family
as the ideal that capital
is most comfortable
with in order to
reproduce the labor power.
So you have all these institutions
but then these institutions
do not always work
as reliably as possible because look,
we're at Yale and we're
teaching "Capital Volume I",
i.e., we are encouraging
you to actually think
about the system rather
than comply with the system.
So there's always this sort
of contradictory relationship
between the processes of the
production of commodities
and the processes of the
production of labor power.
So slide five, please.
And we can see that this
contestation happens.
I'm not sure
if you can see both of
the photographs very well,
that this contestation then can happen
both at the point of
production and outside of it.
The first photo is of
homeowners in Chicago,
actually protesting redlining.
And the second is a point of production
obviously a workers strike at Woolworth's.
And we'll go talk about this more later.
So SRT then is at its core concerned
with the gendered racialized
reproduction of labor power,
and "Capital" as text is
fundamentally concerned
with how surplus value is produced
and with what consequences,
then how are the two related?
So positions such as Ellen Woods above
that we talked about,
try to demonstrate that
capitalist social relations
as they unfold historically ought
to be theoretically separated
out from the abstract or logical
architecture of capitalism.
So in this view, you can
have a historic capitalism
which is how it really
happens, but "Capital Volume I"
it can be argued is
actually the abstraction
and it's not really about
history or anything.
So this particular derivation of capital
and approach to capitalism are in my view,
actually at odds with
both Marx's methodology
and the project of Capital.
"Capital Volume I",
is individually about
the value form of labor.
And we can certainly find passages
in Marx, which might support the argument
that economic categories ought
to be considered distinctly
from their historic unfolding.
However we cannot lose
sight of the fact that
what distinguishes Marxist method from
non-Marxist ones, say Ricardo's concept
of fixed essences is that
Marx rejects a separation
between reality and its apprehension
in thought instead his
methodology establishes
a dialectical unity between them operating
simultaneously at both
logical and historical levels.
To be clear, Marx is not
proposing a simple unity
between theory and reality
in any naturalistic way
but of how theoretical categories
actually derive from
historic developments.
This does not mean that such
categories are reflective
of immediate appearances.
Indeed, as we know, from
our reading of Marx,
they may be they're mirror opposites
rather his method discloses
a constant upward spiral movement
between theory and reality
or appearance and essence
however you want to think about it,
becoming more complex
at each successive level of determination.
So this relationship
between "Capital Volume I"
one as a theoretical text and
history or reality existing
outside of the text is often
classed as a relationship
between abstract categories
and concrete histories, right?
So far we've argued
that there is a relationship
between the abstract categories
and concrete history, but
actually Marx goes much further
than this simple relationality.
So what is an abstract category?
Let's try to unpack that a bit,
an abstract category commonly understood
is a static one, right?
One that doesn't move,
doesn't change with
historical change and so on.
An unmoving part separated
from a dynamic whole
which can reveal to the
analyst key features
of that whole because that
whole is impossible to study
in its totality or, or
complete complexity.
Marx himself uses several
such abstractions,
money, commodity being two
of the most common ones
to understand history and
the nature of capitalism,
but unlike bourgeois
approaches to abstraction,
Marx's methodology
refuses all static forms.
Hence one of the key
theorists, according to me,
of Marx's method
which is Bertell Ollman,
Bertell Ollman has argued
that Marx sets out to
abstract things in his words,
as they really are and
happen making how they happen
part of what they are,
hence capital or labor or money
is not only how capital
appears and functions,
but also how it develops
or rather how it develops its real history
is also part of what it is.
So just to sort of do an aside here,
if you remember in the German ideology,
he and Engels mocked Bruno Bauer
for attempting to prove an
antithetical relationship
between nature and history as if,
and Marx says and I quote,
"These were two separate things."
Unquote.
In contrast, a Marxist abstraction.
So this sort of category that you abstract
from the whole to understand the whole,
a Marxist abstraction encloses within it,
both a history of its becoming
while disclosing its possible future.
For instance, within the
abstract category capital
we also find it's past,
which is the so-called
primitive accumulation as well
as forecast of its
future constant expansion
through surplus value extraction,
the accumulation drive, creating
the world market and so on.
So the past as well as
the future is enclosed
in the abstract category of capital.
So while we might find these categories
in whole or in part in
other epochs of history,
i.e., in other modes of production
like we will find money
or labor and so on.
They either remain
unrealized in their function
or play entirely different roles
from their current incarnation.
When they combine in the
capitalist mode of production,
they do so as being simultaneously
saturated with their past
while establishing new
relationships within themselves.
So the history of pre-capitalist practices
thus cannot be separated or severed
from the explanatory
categories of capitalism.
So this is a digression
in how the methodology
that I think is useful in going
back to reading "Capital".
And once we have this methodology in place
let us now revisit Ellen Wood's
claim that the extraction of surplus
value is the primary concern for
capital and hence how
that process happens,
i.e., whether that process happens
to racialized gendered or ableist means
is actually incidental to
capital's central pursuit, right?
So remember we are now talking.
So if we use that idea
then Marxist methodology doesn't
really apply because as we tried
to establish that the abstract in
Marx actually discloses the history
of the category itself and
discloses its unfolding.
So as we've already then established
that even abstract categories
in Marx carry historical lineages
and future illusions,
in a sense, this should
be enough to reject
Woods' claim of capitalist indifference
but there is actually a case to be
made for indifference as
regards to Capitalist forms
not however, in the way that
Ellen Wood conceives of it.
So let us take the abstract category labor
as it appears in Marx,
it is just banally true
that human beings have always labored
in a diversity of historical
epochs and social formations,
but labor as a simple
category that Marx uses
to build the theoretical infrastructure
of "Capital Volume I",
when economically conceived
in this simplicity says Marx
it becomes, and I quote,
"A modern category as the relations
which create this simple abstraction."
So capital, so under capitalism
labor as such, not any
specific kind of labor,
not the sort of act of building a table
or teaching or cooking,
not any specific kind
of labor, but labor as
such becomes the basis
for the creation of wealth.
To conceive of labor in this,
its most simple form was
an analytical leap taken
by classical political economy
which actually Marx is
very much in support of
and absolutely gives props to Adam Smith.
He's wrote, "It was a
tremendous advance on the part
of Adam Smith to throw aside
every limiting specification
of wealth creating activity,
not only manufacturing or commercial
or agricultural labor but one as well
as the others labor in general.
So Smith first came upon this idea
and Marx follows very much from it.
But how did classical
political economy arrive
at this generalized form of labor?
Not simply because laboring
was an historical category,
common to all epochs,
but because labor under
capitalism had become
for the first time labor in general.
So the theoretical conception
of this general or simple form
of labor was only possible
in the historical actuality
a very developed totality
of real kinds of labor
of which no single one was
any longer predominant."
Unquote, as Marx put it.
So abstraction in this case,
the abstract category of labor arose
from the very many
determinations of the concrete,
while the concrete could only be conceived
of as such through the simple abstraction.
So it is only when the system itself,
the historical system
itself was indifferent
to what kind of labor remember
the first like five chapters
of "Capital Volume I", right?
So all of you've gone through it.
So the most general abstractions
Marx reminds us arise only
in the midst of the richest
possible concrete development.
And I quote Marx, where one thing appears
as common to many to all then it ceases
to be thinkable in a
particular form alone, right?
So it was that historical development
and the concrete unfolding of it that
allowed classical political
economists to have
to make that analytical
leap towards abstraction.
So you can see here
I'm sort of building this
argument that the concrete
and the abstract actually
have a relationship
in Marx in the methodology.
So now you can see where
I will go with this
with whether the creation of
surplus value is indifferent
to how surplus value is produced, right?
So that's the argument we are leading
up to with all this discussion
on the abstract and the concrete.
It is because indifference
in real sense is expressed
in the historical form
that it can be grasped
as such in the abstract theoretical form.
It is because individuals
in capitalist society
can fluidly move from one
form of labor to another
that both the category labor and labor
in reality has become, and I quote Marx,
"The means of creating wealth
in general and has ceased
to be organically linked
to particular individuals
in any specific form.
Hence, far from there being
an abstract capitalism,
indifferent to historical forms
and historical capitalism marked
by concrete social relations,
Marx's methodology urges critical thought
to unite theory and reality
in actually transformatively
radical ways, right?
So we don't need to have this sort
of historical capitalism
versus abstract capitalism.
We should actually think
about Marxist methodology
challenges us to think
about rejecting this sort
of a division in thinking,
but think about a dialectical unity
within the categories themselves.
So accordingly, Marx posits abstract labor
in "Capital Volume I".
And you are all very aware of this,
very carefully and he posits it
as one aspect of his
labor theory of value,
subjective forms are concrete labor,
the analytical twin of abstract labor,
and social labor through which
the value form is organized
are all understood
as different aspects of labor
operating as a unity, right?
So most importantly, "Capital Volume I" is
about why and how abstract labor dominates
over the other aspects and
submits them to the law of value.
So that's really, but it doesn't mean
that there is an abstract
labor that we study
about and then there's concrete labor.
It actually shows you why abstract
labor dominates over concrete labor.
If the other aspects
of labor like concrete
labor and social labor,
appear as muted shadows of abstract labor,
then it is not because Marx is reporting
on reality in any simple way.
These other categories
in capital have a much
more significant role
to play in the totality
of Marx's argument.
Concrete labor, or social labor.
Actually these theoretical
categories actually signal
the limits to capitalism's
ability to reduce workers
to simply being potential
sources of surplus value.
Okay, so we should think
about these categories
not simply as explaining
how surplus value is created
but also these categories
signal the limits
to what capital can extract from us.
So let us look more closely then
at the relationship between abstract
and concrete labor and their
respective roles in capitalism.
A system organized on the basis
of abstract labor as we argued before,
can only appear when different forms
of concrete labor performed
by historically situated people
are forced into a relationship
of equivalence via the market,
production for which takes place solely
for profit rather than for human need.
So the system reproduces
itself through the production
of commodities, a process
involving abstract labor
or labor in its value form
but constantly rubbing
against this process
while nested within it, human
beings reproduce their lives
through concrete,
historically laden actions,
reproduction of life-making practices,
and the reproduction of value
must be simultaneous and continuous.
Which is the reality of capitalism,
but also a sense of anxiety for capital.
Because it does not have the kind
of control it has at the point
of production over the
production of commodities.
It doesn't have the same
control over the production
of life-making or a reproduction
of life-making if you like,
because it doesn't happen
at the point of production.
So slide six, please.
Two preconditions attend
to such a system that is capitalism.
One, that people are forcibly torn
from the means of
production, such that access
to their subsistence or
life-making is only available
through the mechanism of the market.
And second, if the system is able
to ensure its continued reproduction
by reproducing the social
relations that scaffold
the market and the
extraction of surplus value.
In other words, capitalist social
relations must continually reproduce
the worker's dependence on capital.
So both things as you can see here
in this wonderful feminist
graphic from the 1970s,
both things are happening
at the same time,
the woman is split down in the middle,
to my left she is performing
labor in the domestic sphere.
Many of you listening in
can identify with that,
especially during pandemic
times of your children at home
and pulling at your
skirt, and on my right.
She is also working in the
workplace and you can see
I always find this very interesting
because there is a there is a clock
that marks time in the workplace.
So it's a wonderful image
that shows both sides
of capital, how capital
reproduces itself as a system.
So the dominance of abstract
over concrete labor of value,
overused value create the conditions for,
and necessitate the production
of a worker compliant
to capital's every whim.
Okay, because if there
isn't a compliant worker
then there would be no system.
So that's capital's need, right?
But if this were the whole
story of "Capital Volume I",
then celebration of its 150th birthday
would be held at Wall Street.
But how, if at all is then
resistance part of this story.
If Marxist theory requires all parts
of a social totality to be connected
through internal relations
how can resistance to capital
be shown to be imminent
to the reproduction of capital, right?
Because resistance can't
be from the outside.
It can't be in external relations.
That's going against Marxist methodology.
And this is where to go back to our point,
Social Reproduction Theory
deploying capital's methodology,
but building upon some of its silences,
effects a category
transformation of the concept
of labor power as the analytical causeway,
the analytical bridge between
capitalist reproduction
and anticapitalist resistance.
So even the most creative
reading of the concept
of labor power and capital shows,
and this is the feminist big
fight with "Capital Volume I"
one that the text
presupposes the existence
of what is being reproduced.
So labor power is just
there in "Capital Volume I".
Theoretically, it's a
category that's just there.
Discussion of labor power begins not
from where or how it has
been societally produced
but the ways in which
in its commodity form
it sustains the production
of surplus value.
Differently put,
conceptualization of labor power
in the text is limited to the form
in which it is useful to capital.
SRT advocates this capital-oriented
view of labor power
and performs in theory,
a reverse movement away
from the site of commodity production
to the site of the
reproduction of labor power.
So labor power, for those of you,
who've read the text,
I'm talking about the
students in the seminar,
you know that it is nominated variously
in capital as unique,
special, peculiar commodity
because it is presented
as the only commodity
and in Marx's famous words,
whose use value possesses
the peculiar property
of being a source of value.
And I'm so excited to see how Paul Reitter
and Paul North will
translate that passage.
I'm really excited to learn from that.
But SRT reveals that
there is another aspect
to labor powers peculiarity.
It is a commodity undoubtedly
but it is a commodity that is
not produced capitalistically,
that is within the direct ambit
of the capital wage
labor relations, right?
So it's produced outside of it.
The feminist who pioneered
some of this thinking,
Lisa Vogel, has shown that it is produced
and reproduced what Lisa Vogel calls
a kin-based site, which is
the working class family.
So this insight is crucial
and it is crucial in
three important respects.
First, because it expresses
the dialectical unity
of what we had argued previously
between the historical and
logical form of capital, right?
Labor power, SRT shows, can
only become available to capital
through distinct, but reliable
sets of gendered, racialized,
social relations that create their
own institutional forms of sustenance,
such as the monogamous
heteronormative family forum.
Older historical forms maybe recast,
new forums may be created and mobilized,
but it is only through
concrete, social relations
and centers human labor,
that labor power is produced
and made available to capital.
Second, being attentive to labor power,
not as it appears before capital,
but as it is produced and
reproduced SRT introduces,
or rather restores,
to capitalists totality a
sphere of social relations
where life-making activities proliferate.
While capital's goal is
to increase surplus value
in the sphere of production.
The worker's goal is to
enhance her quality of life,
for qualitative enrichment
of her labor power
and herself would through the
satisfaction of her needs.
SRT reminds us of the power of these life
making activities by workers
for they seek to impose breaks
on the process of accumulation
as capital is forced to pay
for them through wages
and social benefits.
So let's go back and look
at this picture, right?
So look at what is to my
left side of the graphic,
which is one way that this woman worker
could enhance the quality of the left side
of her work sphere is by
having public childcare.
The crying child on the
floor would actually be
at a public well-funded
government childcare institution.
And you can see that she's ironing
so we could have public
laundries and so on.
And so if on the right
side of the graphic,
she went on strike to demand that
then that is actually again,
putting a break on the
accumulation process
for her to enhance the
quality of her life.
So you see there is a relationship
between the production
of commodity and the
reproduction of labor power.
So finally, there is a clear
strategic component to SRT.
Life-making social practices
by workers are not simply
conjurers of activities to satisfy needs.
They have the potential to carry
an anticapitalist charge,
struggles to enhance
or expand such practices will
always reveal the balance
of class forces, that I want
better public health care.
In fact, I want my healthcare to be free.
I want education to be free.
This is not to claim that
any, or all struggles
by workers to improve their living
conditions are all
anti-systemic struggles,
but it is to argue
that they carry that the potential
for that sort of anticapitalist charge.
The struggles that are
about enhancing the sphere
of life-making for workers can
thus reveal often implicitly
but sometimes explicitly the upper limits
to what the working class
can claim in its goal
for self enhancement and liberation,
thus they carry the potential
of teaching the worker
and struggle the most important
political lesson about capitalism,
that while the wage
for life-making activities
can never be free of the drive
for accumulation and thus
real emancipation life
and labor is only possible
with the abolition of
the wage form, right?
So we can demand for instance,
that we have free abortion on demand.
We have free medical
care or free education.
And in certain contexts
capital will even grant that
but immediately try to claw
it back when it can, right?
So again, this sort of
struggle to constantly win back
from capital, our life-making activities
or our potential for expanded
life-making activities
is a continuous process
and it'll never end till the abolition
of the wage form itself.
So if SRT establishes the
non-capitalistic production
of labor power and its reproduction
through particular gendered
and racialized social relations
it also raises more troubling questions
about the procedures of its reproduction.
The production of value and
the extraction of surplus value
as demonstrated in capital,
have certain tendencies
and counter tendencies
that seek equalization
throughout the system.
But the hallmark of capitalism,
surely is it's deep social inequality
both between the capitalist class
and workers within the classes themselves.
So the production of surplus value unpacks
the secret of inequalities
between capital and labor
but what explains the sustenance
of inequality amongst workers?
What explains the wage gap?
What explains the racialized wage gap?
So traditional Marxist
accounts of racism within
the working class for
example, locate the production
and reproduction race in
labor market competition.
The argument goes that workers compete
with each other as individual
sellers of labor power
on the market, and
historically dominant sections
of the class compete with
the more vulnerable sections
of the class over jobs, pensions
and social benefits, right?
So all of the racism is
then reproduced or produced
in the first place within
the labor market itself
for competing jobs and so on.
So I agree with the broad
outlines of this account,
but I think SRT urges
us to push the question
of differentiation further
and pitch it, not just at the
level of the labor market,
but at the level of production
of the value of labor power.
So the labor market is about the price
of labor power, but we want
to situate the question
at the level of production
of the value of labor power.
So the value of labor power
as a commodity, we all
know, and this is again
your first five chapters
of "Capital Volume I",
like all commodities under capitalism,
the value of labor power is determined
by the value of the means of subsistence
that is needed for it's production.
So next slide, please.
So this is your,
sorry, Audrey, the next slide please.
Oh, there we go, thank you.
It is actually almost
institutionally recognized
sometimes because that's what
the federal minimum wage is, right?
Forget the fact that
it's been stuck there,
but the wage basket as it were,
is your means of subsistence
that creates the labor power.
But Marx reminds us
that for this peculiar
commodity labor power
and in contradistinction
from all the other kinds of
commodities under capitalism
there enters what Marx
calls, quote, unquote,
an historical and moral element
in the determination of its value.
Now, what the hell does that mean?
Because he says that there may be-
- I'm sorry.
- That's okay.
- [Woman] Sorry.
So what is the historical
and moral element?
So Marx introduces this
concept to say this
that there might be a lower limit
to what the laboring body needs
to reproduce itself, right?
So there is only, you
can only like be hungry
to a certain level or
thirsty to a certain level
after which the human body will die.
So there can be a lower limit
to what the body needs to
go to work the next day.
But there can be no fixed upper limit
to the workers necessary needs,
as needs themselves are dynamic,
historically produced, and
shaped by the gains made
by the working class through struggle.
So a worker in the 1930s in Bangladesh,
well, not in Bangladesh
at the time, India,
has to be a worker in
1930s in British India
will have very different
needs from the worker in 2020
in India or Bangladesh, or
the worker in the US today.
So because though what
we think we absolutely
need to go to work the next day
what reproduces our labor power varies
between countries between times.
And so what Marx calls a dynamic process.
So, in the number and extent of
a workers necessary
wants, as Marx's confirms,
are themselves the product of
historical development, right?
So let's go to slide eight.
So we can see in the next slide,
some of the things,
that we have come to accept as,
sorry, the next slide please.
So necessary wants we've come to accept
as something that exists.
And I want to talk about
the two figures here
the correction and law
enforcement in a little bit,
but this week we take for granted
as some of the things today
that we take for granted
as necessary wants that we have
to reproduce as the workers.
So if necessary wants
which determined the value
of labor power are historical and dynamic,
it follows then that different sections
of the working class
produced at different moments
of history will have different standards
of necessary wants, right?
The Irish worker for
Marx in direct contrast
with her English counterpart embodied
this production of
difference for Marx said
that the Irish worker was, and I quote,
"At that level of wage labor who accepted
the most animal minimum of needs
and subsistence in her
exchange with capital."
Unquote.
So the Irish worker accepted
a much higher degree of exploitation than
the English worker, according to Marx.
So this version of productive difference
then situates difference
in the very operation
of labor powers reproduction, which means
that labor power has
already been differentiated
reproduced even before it reaches
the field of labor market competition.
Indeed, even the access or
entry into labor market cannot
be a presupposition as such access
and entry across different sections
of the class exists precisely due
to differential reproduction.
So now let's go back
to the correction and and
the police, law enforcement,
actually these two categories
in any working class community has
a very differential effect on
black workers, Latino workers,
than they have on white workers.
The kind of disciplining
categories that exist have
very different kind of expectations
and notion of necessary wants
than between black and white
workers or Latino workers.
So attention to social reproductive
activities then reveal the
specific social processes
through which certain workers
embody certain qualities
of labor power arrive at
the doorstep of capital,
more vulnerable and degraded than others.
Ruthlessly depressed
levels of necessary wants
for Latino workers in
the US is one example
of brutally differentiated
processes of social reproduction
between migrant workers and
their citizen counterparts.
The median space per person
in a Latino household in
the US is 350 square feet.
80 square feet less than than that
of the average non migrant family living
below the poverty line.
So in a similar vein, I don't need to go
through all of this,
but if you, if you look
at how COVID-19 has affected
black working class communities
and Latino working class
communities compared
to white working class communities
it is very clear that previous processes
of social differentiation,
redlining, environmental
racism had already
made these communities
far more vulnerable.
So when the disease finally hit
it obviously had a differential response
in these communities.
As well as, not just those kinds
of redlining and environmental racism,
but where you know, factories
producing environmentally
degrading products are
cited far more frequently
in black communities than they are
in non-black communities, right?
So this has been established.
"The New York Times" has actually
done pretty decent reporting
on redlining and industrial
waste in recent times.
So we are looking at then
the factor that certain communities
are historically reproduced
to be more vulnerable even
before they hit the labor market.
So the idea that the
differentiation happens
in the labor market, then
we need to sort of revise
and look at these veins of
social reproduction that exists
before the worker gets to
the door of the labor market.
So access to housing, police
violence, substandard schools
and healthcare are obvious
ingredients that determine
the level of necessary wants
for a section of the working
class and thereby determined
and lower the value of their labor power.
But the lowering of value
for one section of workers
always has a conditioning impulse
for all sections for lower wages
for some workers can allow
capital to rationalize
and lower wages for all workers.
So degraded, social reproduction
of racialized workers
thus can help establish a regime
of cheapened wages for all.
So I want to conclude by circling back
to the morphology of labor
power, as within it is fused
the argument offered in "Capital"
and the significance of SRT.
So while it is true, that capitalism tries
to produce the working class it needs,
"Capital Volume I" shows
us that workers struggle
against the wage form is a necessary part
of the internal dynamics of the
system and its reproduction.
The worker will always tend
towards the development
of her own needs through
life-making activities.
While capital will continually tend
towards limiting such activities
to increase its share of surplus value,
and hence civilization.
Collective organizing on the
basis of solidarity remains
the only way the working class can
win this unequally resourced
battle against capital.
The warning we received from SRT, however,
is that a multi-racial
working class unity will
not arise spontaneously through
either left-wing propaganda
or volunteerism for the differentiation
of the working class is
produced and sustained
at a cellular level of the system.
It is clear that vicious border policies,
gendered and racialized
labor regimes are only some
of the ways in which capitalism seeks
to globally reproduce the working class
in combined, but deeply unequal ways.
Against this warning,
the aspiration we received
from SRT is equally important,
as a unitary theory,
revealing the relationship
between point of production of commodities
and the spaces of
reproduction of labor power,
SRT imbues every struggle for
enhanced social reproduction
with anticapitalist possibilities.
A working class movement that will be able
to give form to such
possibilities cannot simply
retrace older cultures of solidarity
but it will have to
actively forge new wants.
Such a movement must champion
with equal vigor working
class struggles based in communities
around water, around police
violence, around housing,
alongside workplace struggles.
It will have to learn to articulate
demands on a double register,
simultaneously appealing to
the universal and the specific.
We should simultaneously
demand universal health care
but make specific demands for access
to reproductive care,
for better healthcare for
black people and so forth.
These should not be understood as
two counter posed strategies,
but as to moments in a
single necessary process.
Next slide please.
So if "Capital Volume I" remains
one of the most savage critiques
of capitalism as a system,
SRT, or Social Reproduction Theory,
can perhaps be thought of as animating
that critique with embodied
voices of workers in struggle.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
This is the hole that
we fall into at the end
of every talk, where there
would be thunderous applause.
I know that that's happening
and that there's also feelings
of a possible new solidarity.
So thank you for the talk.
I want to kick
off with a question and then
we can start asking folks
if they want to put questions
in the chat and we will
take them in order.
I want to ask you this question.
So I've thought for a long time
that the division of labor is
one of the fundamental motors
of "Capital Volume I", one and
of capital as Marx sees it.
That's not just a static thing
or an advantage to capital
that labor be divided,
but it's a kind of dynamic motor
which keeps getting divided and redivided
for the purpose of
increasing accumulation.
And I really liked that
the reproductive space
is brought into this by SRT,
it was always there,
but it's brought into this as an effect
of the division of labor,
part of the division
of labor almost as though
there's a continuum
and that the production
floor is right next
to the reproduction floor.
And these forces are
working on both of them.
I guess I want to ask,
if you see them still as,
or if you see them as
qualitatively different,
these two moments?
If we should consider them both labor
in the same way,
if putting them on a continuum makes
a stronger possibility for solidarity.
And if there have been examples
in history where let's
say the domestic sphere
and the production sphere have
gone out on strike together
you showed two images and
the woman is split in half,
but are there examples that you know of
where the solidarity has happened?
- Great question, Paul.
So first of all the division is
in a sense when we're talking about it,
we're talking about it
to make it easy to analyze, right?
So the division is the
theoretical division,
but in reality, you know,
the process has to happen
simultaneously, right?
So it's a conceptual
division that we've created
in order to understand the process.
So let me start by saying
how it's different rather
than how it's same, because
I think we've talked
about how it's simultaneous
and how it's same.
So let's think about that.
So first of all, domestic
labor while completely
the precondition if you
like to wage labor, right?
So if there was no domestic labor
there would be no wage labor.
So while it's a precondition to wage labor
however domestic labor
does not produce value.
So we could not have equalized time
for diaper change across
all household units
of a social formation,
and thereby produce value from it.
So it doesn't produce value
in that sense, even though it
is actually the precondition
to the production value.
So that's one for sure.
We cannot have equalization across units.
So we cannot have abstract labor
in the domestic theory,
it has to be by necessity concrete labor.
So that's one.
And the second thing is that
I've said that capital does not have
full control over this sphere,
but often when I've
talked about it this way
it may be misunderstood
sometimes by saying that it
lies outside of the circuit
of value production.
Well, it doesn't.
So what I mean is it doesn't fall
within the direct control of capital.
It doesn't mean it lies
outside of the circle.
A very simple example would be you working
in your garden or one working
in their garden is a
non-value producing work.
It's a life-making activity.
It's a concrete labor.
It's a beautiful thing.
However, you can only work
in your garden when your wage
labor schedule allows you to
so you can't simply work in
your garden when you want to.
So the way that work is different,
the way that work is
done is actually shaped
by the impulses of wage work.
So even though it is not.
But again, because it's
human concrete labor
it constantly has these
potentials for disruption.
And obviously wage labor does that too.
That's what a strike is,
but we should also think
about the moments of
disruption that can happen here
because capital doesn't
have direct control.
To come to the more
important question is when
have they ever struck work simultaneously?
Let's remember that the two
most important revolutions
of modern times, the
French and the Russians,
1789 and 1917, both started
off with bread rights,
which was, you know, women.
and this is acknowledged in all
of the contemporary writing
that it was women breaking
through Baker's shops
where bread was being horded,
or looting shops and
demanding bread for themselves
and their families that
actually sparked off
the revolution which set off
then a series of wage strikes.
So it, so the question
for us as social justice
activists should be
to consider not so much that
these two spheres are separate
but to consider that sometimes
a resistance will spark
in one sphere, but can easily
spread to the other, right.
- That's very helpful
while we're waiting for
people to post some questions.
If they have them, maybe I'll follow up.
I wonder if you could say this is more
of a technical issue in in the dialectic,
but I wonder if you
could say a little more
about how the domestic sphere,
the reproductive sphere is included.
So for example, I can see it
as a possible point of resistance,
because there's just
other values or purposes,
you call them life-making, right?
And there's remnants of,
not just remnants, but
full-fledged indorsement
of other hermeneutic
frameworks like religious ones
or whatever it be
outside of the workplace.
And even inside of the workplace
that go along alongside it.
So you could say, well,
life-making is a separate value
and it can offer a point
of resistance on its terms at times.
But there's also a pressure
from capital, let's say,
to reduce that life-making activity
to the absolute minimum because
even though it doesn't contribute to value
or you could say you can't generalize it.
So you can't measure
value on diaper changes.
That's a really useful way to put it.
The worker has to let's
say cover in the value
of their labor, not only
herself, but her dependence.
So it's contributing in some
way to the value of labor.
Like the magnitude of the
value of labor is also
how much this heteronormative
family requires to go on.
So if capital could get rid of it,
I guess it would, no?
- Get rid of the family?
- Domestic sphere,
reproductive labor, as much as possible.
I'm thinking of the other side,
which is not resistance
from those other positions,
but the interest would be kind of like,
to get rid of it.
So it doesn't seem to be possible
but I wonder if you see pressures
from that side also, whatever
that means, automation.
- So to get rid of it,
because it wants more time
in the wage sphere, is
that what you're saying?
- It would theoretically
reduce the value of labor
if labor didn't also have to provide
for the lives of the
laborers dependence, right?
- Sure. Yeah.
I mean, let's think about
the historical examples here
that's a really, really great point,
actually, Paul and I'm
very grateful for it
because we should have
talked about it a little bit.
Like let's think about
the historical origins
of capitalism as a historic system in,
let's say, Northern England, right?
So, I mean, this is where
Marx in volume one talks
so laudably about the
factory inspectors, right?
Because what capital was actually doing
was pulling all of the labor
into the factory and therefore
thereby completely undermining
social reproduction
of the working class family.
So people were just dying.
And I always say, when I teach
"Capital Volume I", one is
that the companion piece is
not necessarily, excuse me.
but the companion piece
is actually Angels'
condition of the working
class in England, right?
Because that shows you in very
descriptive ways, what happens if a
social reproduction capital does not kind
of close it's eyes to that loss of profit
by maintaining the working-class family?
What happens?
It undermines its very
possibility of existence, right?
Because without the working class family
without the life-making,
there would be no workers.
So this is in a way something that we have
to actually think about really
and this is why I'm so grateful
for the point you bring up,
we have to think about this very clearly
in terms of the current
ecological emergency
because accumulation is actually pushing,
not so much in terms of
the 18th century or early 19th century
sort of the extinguishing
of the working class family.
But it is pushing again
to a point where it's undermining
even the possibility of value
production and accumulation,
by pushing the planet
to the edge of climate catastrophe
which will undermine its own
condition of possibility.
So I think this is the
dynamic that we have
to be attentive to
constantly under capitalism,
that what it can get away with
by not giving and what it can,
what it is forced to give,
albeit reluctantly in order
to ensure this continuous
reliable production, reproduction circuit.
- That's very helpful. Thank you.
And I love the picture of
capital, the capital system
as being this kind of
anxious little person
worried about the incursions on all sides.
We have some questions and I want to start
with a question by Elena
Gomes if we can unmute Elena.
And if you don't mind asking your question
- Hi, thank you so much.
I was just wondering if
you could talk a little bit
about how you see the
kind of historicization
of SRT in relation to Marxist feminism,
particularly in the 1970s,
I'm interested in kind
of whether you see this
as like a theoretical departure
or if it's an extension or
if it's kind of out of a different
tradition and whether SRT
is able to ask questions
that were maybe not available
to the theorists such as Selma James
and Leopoldina Fortunati, et cetera?
- Shall I just answer or wait for more?
- Would you like to gather a few
or do you want to answer one by one?
It's up to you.
- Let me just try to answer this
because I think it's a very important one.
So thank you for that, Elena.
So I think first of all
we should start any discussion about 1970s
Marxist feminism by
saying that this version
of SRT, as we develop
from "Capital Volume I"
in more recent times,
and just to go back,
Lisa Vogel, who kind of
pioneered some of this thinking,
Lisa's book was actually
published in the early eighties.
So even though it has had a sort
of regeneration in recent times
and we can talk about why
that regeneration has happened
because I have some ideas about that,
Lisa's work actually
isn't too sort of modern,
"Marxism and the Oppression of Women"
was first published in 1983.
So, but it is actually,
it forms a departure
from the earlier Marxist feminist thinking
on domestic labor.
Because SRT, as we talked about,
we talk a lot about domestic labor
but it is a very different
kind of placing and positioning
and theorizing and
exploring of domestic labor,
very different from Selma James
and Sylvia Federici and
Leopoldina Fortunati.
So the first thing to say is
I think I owe a debt of
gratitude, a big debt
of gratitude to the 1970s
domestic labor debate.
And the reason for that
is remember domestic labor
as a theoretical category lies,
the seeds of it lie in "Capital Volume I".
The discussion of it happens
in early Marxist and socialist thought
one can think about Alexandra Kollontai.
But it's kind of that discussion
is submerged and lost in history.
And it is these comrades
and activists and scholar
activists of the 1970s who
resurrect this category
but politicize it and theorize it.
So we all actually will owe
a real debt of gratitude
to these thinkers and activists.
And they don't just theorize it.
They actually go to battle on it.
Which is most, most important.
So having said that,
I also have to say, as
you might've guessed,
as I indicated that I
don't think I don't agree
with the way they theorize domestic labor
because these theorists argue
that domestic labor
actually creates value.
and I don't think it does,
it is the precondition for value,
but it doesn't actually create value.
So that's a sort of
major difference we have
in the way it is theorized.
And because theorized slightly differently
it often can have different
strategic conclusions, right?
So if we realize that domestic
labor can create value,
then we can think about
ways in which striking
or demanding wages for domestic labor
is actually going to disrupt capital.
And we have to and again,
if there is a strike
to stop domestic labor
as the women's strikes have shown
then that is actually a very
powerful means to do that.
But we also have to think about the ways
in which wage labor has
a conditioning impulse
on domestic labor.
And so to separate those two in my mind is
is not gonna be helpful,
but I want to end with saying
that if there is a barricade,
then I think all of us are on
the same side of that barricade.
Vis-a-vis how we proceed
in the feminist struggle.
And I think these discussions
and debates and differences
are actually very productive
in which ways of moving forward.
- There's a healthy roll of
questions in in the chat.
So I'm going to read, do
you want to take them one
by one or do you prefer grouping?
- It's okay.
Whichever.
- So the next one I'm gonna read
out from Vanessa Gubbins
following up on that one.
Could you say something more
about the potential of
anticapitalist charge
in life-making activities in relation
to the difficulties that can
arise due to real subsumption?
- Real subsumption,
could you talk about it a little more?
- Vanessa, do you want to hop on?
- Just tell me how you
relate sort of domestic labor
or life-making activity
to real subsumption.
What did you mean by that?
- We're just unmuting and
getting ourselves ready.
Audrey, can you unmute Vanessa?
- [Vanessa] Can you hear me?
- [Paul] Yes, we have you now.
- [Vanessa] Hi, sorry about that.
Thank you so much for
such an incredible talk.
I actually think you already answered
my question when you were
answering Paul's earlier.
But just to say,
I was just thinking of real subsumption
as the way in which
the reproductive sphere
the life-making sphere
is already determined
by what's happening
and where capital more
directly has an effect.
And I was thinking about the
the later chapters in "Capital",
where you go from formal
subsumption to real
subsumption is once capital has
become a totalizing system that
affects absolutely everything
and everything is read
through that lens, even
life-making activities.
So I thought that would perhaps,
what has been rendered as somewhat
of a more pessimistic Marx in some regard.
But I think I was just wondering
if you had any thoughts
on how that could affect the potential,
the revolutionary potential
of these fears that are
less directly controlled
by wage labor?
- No, that's a great question.
Thank you, Vanessa.
So I'm gonna start, I'm
gonna try to answer that
with the lyrics of a union
song from the earlier part
of the 20th century and the
American Union Movement.
It's a song that I find fascinating
because there is a recognition
in the early union movement
of the unity of these spheres
that you're talking about, right?
So this song goes, and
I will not subject you
to my singing, but the song
goes, it's a strike song.
And it's supposedly from the workers
and it says something like my children
are seven and numbers and something
and they're all starving,
but the refrain is striking,
striking we're striking
for pairs of shoes.
And then then there is another description
of all the things that
the family is deprived of.
And then it says striking, striking,
we're striking for bottles of milk.
So in other words,
there's a recognition
in the actual struggle
which is your world of
real subsumption, right?
Where everything is under
the dominance of capital
but the reason why you are engaged
in wage labor is not for money,
but for what money can buy.
So that so in other words,
the relationship between wage labor
and life is constant and
is actually not ruptured
in the consciousness of the worker,
where it gets ruptured is in later,
both the left movement
as well as the union movement,
where we see that in the workplace,
we are fighting for wages.
Well, actually let's reverse that idea
and say, yes, we're fighting for wages
but we're actually fighting
for an enhancement of life.
That's why we want higher wages, right?
Because we want more relaxation time.
We want better healthcare.
We want better food for our families.
So that union song, actually for me
unites these two spheres
in a very beautiful way
because there's a
recognition in the early part
of the union movement in this
country that the two spheres
are intimately connected.
And we are actually all fighting
for life-making activities
and the expansion of
life-making activities.
And in fact, the wage
is an unnatural shadow
that falls between ourself
and our means of sustaining that set.
There should not be
that unnatural divide
between us and our means
of subsistence, but the wage
is an artificial barrier
between those two, which is why one of,
the young SRT theorists
Aaron Jaffe has written recently
written a short essay where he talks
about the potential of these life
making explorations under the pandemic,
where the pandemic has kind
of agitated the ubiquity
and the essential nature
of the wage, right?
That that we constantly go
to work and we get the
wage and we come home
with the disruption of things
under under the pandemic
we can see almost
transparently the unnaturalness
of the wage, right?
Because there's been so much
succession in the workplace
and in the home, we also see what
is actually essential work
to keep the world going.
And it's not stockbrokers and bankers
it is actually life-making
activities of teachers,
nurses and people in the
whole care home, et cetera.
So I don't know if this
answers your question
but I don't think it, the architecture
of "Capital Volume I"
actually never distracts
from the fact that under real subsumption
that there is this sort
of hegemonic monolith that
is capital that
extinguishes all possibility
of workers struggle.
In fact, what it reveals
is this constant dynamic
of workers trying to win
back life-making resources
from capital and capital constantly having
to negotiate as to how much it can give
and how much it will give,
or is forced to give.
- [Vanessa] Thank you so
much, that was wonderful.
- I want to ask a very
short follow-up to that.
How can you tell in life-making activities
which ones are for life and
which ones are for capital?
- That's a really, really
interesting question.
So this I think, connected to
your earlier question, Paul,
that while we think
about in concrete labor
and concretely laboring bodies,
we can never forget that
we live under the shadow
of a systemic reproduction
of abstract labor, right?
So well,
kissing your loved one
is a life-making activity you can often
finding time to do so is part
of what makes it difficult sometimes.
But what is life-making activity?
I think there the problem,
the fact that you could
even ask that question
should alert us to the fact that
through historically life-making
activities are continuously
commodified, right?
So, just like domestic labor
is actually commodified.
if you have enough money
as a woman, you can get
away with not doing a jot
of domestic labor and actually farming it
out to immigrant women of
color who will come and sweep
and dust and clean and do
whatever it is in your home.
And you wouldn't have to
do a bit of work, right?
So capital will constantly,
as we know, will try to
commodify every element
even in the sphere of life-making, right.
However, this does not finally,
I want to constantly go back
to the idea that that does not mean
that it always succeeds,
that that charge and that dynamic
of concrete labor continuously remains
and actually has to remain
if capital has to has to survive.
So women or female marked
bodies have to give birth.
Sometimes they'll give birth
under certain kinds of
historical conditions
and other times under
others, but those sorts
of processes have to
continuously take place.
And it actually isn't
capitalist's worth to actually
factory farm an entire
generation of workers, right?
It just isn't the kind of
investment it has to make
in order to do that in
changing social mores
in creating such factory
farms, it just isn't worth it.
I mean, it gets this
work done very cheaply,
free of cost in most
working class households.
Why should it invest
in that kind of fully auto,
well, again, you cannot
fully automate care.
I mean, this is the big thing, right?
So they try to mechanically
reproduce care,
especially in the
privatized medical industry.
And we see the problems with that, right?
So when you say that
there are little beepers that the
nurse will only stay by your
bedside for five minutes
and has to take the take on on the child.
And the nurse has to complete
X number of bed visits per day.
It just doesn't work.
In the sense that care cannot be
mechanized in that extent.
And that's a problem that
capital has as it were.
- So I'm gonna tell my partner that
she's not kissing me just
to make sure I'm home
at the end of the day to make dinner.
(laughs)
Now is a good moment to, I think
turn to Gabriel Wyman's question.
I don't know, Gabriel, I
think just maybe left the room
but if Gabriel is here,
this was a question
about the commodification
of reproductive labor.
Can we open up Gabriel's voice?
Gabriel is here but on the phone,
but we should still be able to unmute.
Gabriel, would you like
me to read the question?
Okay.
This is the most bizarre way
to communicate with anyone.
Thanks for a great talk,
Gabriel says, it strikes me
you mainly consider SRT in relation
to its input to the value of labor power,
as itself an un-commodified form of labor.
I'm curious what you make of
the growing commodification
of reproductive labor, which
you just began to talk about,
which often occurs
through the social state
in partial or limited commodified forms.
What is the significance of
the absorption of so much
of this labor into the labor
market in the last 50 years?
And what should we make
of the historical limits
to capital that have
arisen in its employment?
- So I think by historical limits,
I think that's what you talked about,
that you can't mechanize care completely.
So you can commodify domestic labor
and the reproduction of
life to a certain extent
but you cannot mechanize
or commodify it entirely.
And so that would be my first kind of
kind of response to you.
The other side of it is that when you,
I mean, my friend and
colleague in UMass Amherst
Nancy Fulvert, who's a feminist economist.
She talks about, for instance
one of the problems of workers in
the care industry striking, right?
So she calls it the love problem.
So what's the love problem?
That often, especially for
home health care workers,
those who come into the home to care
for the elderly, et cetera,
who, by the way, did the majority
of the caring for our
elders during this pandemic
and were primarily women of color.
And so we're absolutely
at the sort of the full blast
of the of the disease, of the virus.
So what happens with
home health care workers?
Because care is such a sort of human,
I want to say human and
indeed anticapitalist impulse.
Care and love are human
and anticapitalist impulses
that we carry as a species.
So even when you commodify it,
it actually creates
certain problems, right?
So for instance, with a
home health care worker
she gets so involved in the care
of her patient, of her client,
the person she's providing care for,
that when it comes to striking,
she feels well I can't strike
because this will leave
this really vulnerable
person high and dry,
and this actually will
affect their life chances.
So how can I strike?
Right?
So this is something that
care workers face all the time
in terms of striking.
That whenever as we all know,
there was a wonderful wave
of teacher's strike in this
country two years ago in 2017.
The first thing was
oh, how could you be
so selfish and strike?
Because this affects the lives
and futures of our children.
Okay.
So when nurses go on strike,
how can you possibly strike?
Because you are endangering the health,
the very life, the messy,
fleshy life of human beings.
So care work at this kind of,
so in other words, it is not
just care workers commodified,
but the impulse to care
is often weaponized
by capital to actually stop care workers
from striking, right?
So that very impulse that makes
us human capital weaponizes against us.
So you can strike because
you ought to care.
I think my answer to that,
I learned actually from
concrete worker struggles.
So workers then had to devise a
way to actually frame their struggle,
which shows that they're
striking because they care.
So it is because they
care for the future lives
of their students, of their patients, so
that they may care
properly and sustainably
that they are striking.
So in other words in all
of these care work strikes
that you, if you follow,
as I do, you will see
that workers reframe the struggle
into actually talking about the depths
of care that they have for their patients
and for their students,
which is why they're forced to strike.
So I remember 2012 the
Chicago Teacher's Union
when they went for strike that was like,
you know the first
teacher's strike in so many,
so many years of recent memory,
and it was such a great strike.
And remember that for the Chicago teachers
80% of their students
are students of color.
And the Mayor of Chicago
at the time closed schools
mostly on the South Side of Chicago where
all the black children
and Latino children went to school, right?
But the framing I've thought
of this Chicago teacher's
strike was so wonderful
said that our working conditions are our
students' learning conditions, right?
So in other words, unless
our working conditions
improve we are not able to love
and care for our students in
the way our students deserve.
So it was a very interesting,
to me, learning process
for us to see how
workers in struggled just
as Marx predicted, actually
can reframe the struggle
for care, into talking
about real substantive care,
rather than the weaponized care
that capital forces upon them.
- It makes me think of a beautiful
thing that tends to happen in strikes
and an in group actions that there's
a kind of care that
arises among the strikers.
That's really very different
than anything we're talking
about, kind of the ideal.
We have a set of questions,
and I'm mindful of your labor power.
- That's fine.
- So we'll go a little longer?
You okay?
- Sure, absolutely.
That's a great question.
Because when we say we want
more public service, right?
We want more state intervention
in the market.
So we want these services
taken off the market,
taken off private privatized
sphere and into public control.
So that sounds like a great demand
that we are saying that it should,
healthcare should be public,
or education should be public.
We should have public laundries and so on.
But we are also saying at the same time
if we go via Foucault,
we're also saying that
then that means that the capitalist state
is actually in charge of this.
So, which ought to be a
scary prospect, right?
So we are saying healthcare,
education should be public,
but the word public
actually hides in a way,
the idea that what we mean by public
is also the capitalist state
because we were asking for
state control as it were.
So I think that's a very interesting
and important issue that
we ought to be discussing.
What are the limit?
And this is where I think Marxist
state theory is something that we have to
this should be like the sort
of next chapter of Social
Reproduction Theory.
Like how does Social
Reproduction Theory engage
with Marxist state theory?
Because I think it has to in in a way,
because the state is both the repository
of the disciplining functions of capital
as well as the public functions
of the reproduction of life.
So for instance,
when this early,
I don't know if you're
in Paul's class, Emerson,
but in "Capital Volume
I", Marx, as I said,
is absolutely full of praise
for the government inspectors who come
into the factories and
inspect those conditions.
You know, he goes through
all these blue books
of the inspectors and
and when he writes his,
especially his chapter in the working day.
And that is where we are talking
about that even in the
sphere of production,
in the point of production
question that there
Marx is a welcoming state oversight
over simple operation of
private capital, right?
That it's only the capitalist state
that steps in to actually regulate
how wages are determined
on the factory floor.
And the fact that capital
is actually undermining its
own condition of possibility.
So it's the capitalist state steps
in and says, okay, you need to stop.
And we need to reconfigure
the whole thing here.
And so labor laws are passed
and so on in the course of work,
but it's the same today, right?
So we are asking for
the government to step in
to regulate healthcare or education
as it does in several Nordic countries.
But we cannot forget that it is
the capitalist state, right?
So we are not talking about
workers control over the
process of production.
So the capitalist state
will impose the law of
capital or will impose the law
of value to a certain extent.
And we cannot expect otherwise from it
this is where I think social
democratic governments will join
the First World War in 1914, right.
And shock Lenin and Luxembourg into it.
This is why social democratic
governments today are often
virulent practitioners
of border control,
that they want strong borders
against migrants because
they want to control
the distribution of the wage
within their own national economies.
So on the one hand, and this
is why this contradiction
of the capitalist state
providing life-making activities.
On the one hand we celebrate
we absolutely want free healthcare,
free education from our taxes.
But we cannot forget that the
state ultimately will also
impose the law of value.
Because it is the capitalist state,
it's not a worker's state.
So for instance, what we see is
this dark development in recent times
that in the Nordic countries
there is there's this argument that yes,
we have healthcare but it
is only for Swedish workers.
So all these immigrants need to be driven.
Yes, we have good free education
but it is for our lovely white children.
And not these Muslims.
I was shocked when I went
to Copenhagen last year
it seems like a million years
ago that we used to travel.
So, and the papers where
the left-wing papers were filled with
stories of how Muslims were actually
Muslim immigrants had to
live in ghettos and had
to follow an entirely different program
of sending their children
to school and a daycare
from the the good white citizens
who were full citizens in the country.
So we can see that even
the generalized reproduction
of life-making activities
which we support under the aegis
of the capitalist state
can have its own limits
because it is the capitalist state and not
workers controlled
cooperatives or what have you.
- Got it.
So basically the principle
differences between good and bad,
you answer mostly in terms of like,
the fairness of the state of like racism
and democratic versus
authoritarian tendencies.
So like we can see social
reproductive demands
in the service of like straws, right?
Nazi-ism or whatever.
So it's like, those are the kinds
of places we should distinguish then?
- I'm not sure I understood that.
- Just that my original question
was like the principal demands
between the social reproduction
demands which are disruptive
versus non-disruptive have taken
all those other contexts basically.
- Of course, yes.
- [Gabriel] Yeah. Thank you.
- Elena, if you still have the energy,
give the floor to Paul Reitter
to ask a final question.
- Of course.
- Oh goodness.
That's a lot of pressure after such an-
- Or a comment, or a comment.
- Such an incredible talk
and a wonderful discussion as well.
Thanks so much.
I have a question, a couple of questions,
but I'll limit myself since
the hour is so advanced.
and just ask this one,
you started out talking
about or positioning
your argument in response
to one that suggests
that the book is really very
much focused on abstract labor
and that's ultimately
what's at stake here.
And I thought you did
a really wonderful job
of debunking that in a theoretical way.
And I wonder if there's also a more,
since so much of it is
about the relation between
the theoretical and the empirical
or historical and capital,
if there's an empirical way
to push back against that as well,
because it seems to me that outside
of the working day chapter
there are just so many places in capital
where Marx points out the
tendency of the system
to exploit a particularly
vulnerable population
and use that to make
conditions generally worse
or gain a kind of general advantage.
And so that even if he
doesn't frame this point
as a kind of in part of
this theoretical argument
that it emerges as part
of the argument that he's making,
that there's a tendency in
the system systematically
to go after vulnerable populations.
So that if there's any inequality at all
among the workers, that
inequality will be exploited.
And since it's very hard to imagine
that there could ever be any total lack
of inequality among the working population
under capitalism and its various pressures
that it's therefore seems very unlikely
that this book would be suggesting
that these inequalities
are the inequalities
other than class inequalities
or somehow incidental to
capitalist exploitation.
But there's like there's an accumulation
of evidence that you could
present, in other words,
in response to this,
in addition to the theoretical
argument that you're making.
- Oh, I completely agree.
And I think when I say that
SRT takes issues with certain formulations
in the way labor power
is presented in capital,
I mean I always couch that in saying
in the general framework
that SRT only exists
as a theory using "Capital Volume I"
as its architecture, right?
Because it is from from the understanding
of how labor power is
crucial to the functioning
of capital and how that has a,
and how that creates the conditions
of possibility of the system as a whole
that the starting point of
that is "Capital Volume I".
And there are several, several passages
in the text itself that
point us back constantly
to this reproduction
of labor power and its various modalities
what "Capital Volume I" doesn't do.
But what Marx himself does in other texts
is talk about the gendered
and racialized nature of the reproduction
of labor power and the effect it has.
But I completely agree with you
that the text is actually peppered,
it's studded with various
issues about the potential
of concrete labor, of the
potential of the spaces
of the reproduction of labor
power becoming the sort
of anticapitalist
resistance to wage labor.
So, I mean you never get the impression
through the reading of
the text that abstract,
the dominance of abstract labor
is complete or even absolute in it.
It is that way in the form
in which the system operates, but you get
this constant understanding
of the dynamic,
the pushbacks to it throughout the text.
- There's frequently this message
that in some ways, things
getting worse is progress
because it galvanizes workers resistance
and it ripens the conditions
under which some sort of
meaningful change will occur.
I mean, in the Working Day chapter
there's so much back and
forth where he points out
that the the laws that
regulate factory labor,
that yes, you know, this
is a positive thing.
On the other hand,
they've had these negative
unintended consequences
of intensifying capitalist
production in some ways
making it even more ferocious
because it has to operate
within a more limited time framework.
But at the same time than that very,
what you could see as a setback
has the effect in his estimation
of bringing about
conditions that will hasten
the advance of the workers movement.
And so ultimately that
could be a good thing.
I mean, and this is obviously a discussion
that could go on because
you're at the point of,
and this is one of the of course
one of the challenges
of the book that it is
so big and diverse, and
there are moments where
or there is some amount of variation
among the different parts
and contradictory statements
or at least contrasting statements.
And what reading you'll
come up with can depend
on which parts you choose to emphasize,
these parts where Marx
seems more optimistic
or parts where there's a
certain mood of pessimism
that sets in and to make
your arguments stick.
If you're gonna argue in this way,
then you have to really
catalog exhaustively and show
at the end of the day that
you have a lot of evidence in
in support for what you're saying.
And I do think that there's a lot
of evidence to support
what you were just saying.
And in any case, I feel like I'm now going
from the question mode
to the comment mode.
And I don't want to do that
because this your presentation.
So let me pull back and
give you a last word.
- Oh, that was excellent.
Thank you.
No, no, no.
I wish we had more time.
I always think that,
even after two hours of all this talking.
So I want, obviously this
this is the starting point
I hope have more
discussions on this subject.
I just want to frame sort
of use what you said
as a point of departure
about the sort of
intensification of accumulation
urging workers to higher
levels of struggle.
I just want to use that
as a point of departure
to say but in our current times,
I think we have to frame
that somewhat in the context
of the ecological crisis, right?
So we can think about
expanded reproduction
and extensive drive for accumulation,
urging worker struggle,
but it may all be too late,
in the sense that the
planet may have moved,
or may have moved beyond
a tipping point where such
struggles will ultimately
not yield the results
that we we want, that we
may not be able to move
to an alternative system of capitalism.
And I think here, I find
Walter Benjamin quite useful
in thinking about our
current moment in terms of
the planetary crisis looming over us
that we think about workers'
struggles more as a break
upon this hurtling train of accumulation,
more as a break than as necessarily
anything else that we have to first stop
the current sort of constant drive,
we have to think about workers' struggles,
because otherwise the train is gonna,
and unfortunately we are all on the train,
not just capitalists,
and the train is gonna hurtle
beyond everybody's control
and to the common ruin
of contending classes as
the famous quote goes.
But I don't want to end on
that extremely dark note.
I want to end on the note
that that kind of possibility
of the common wound of contending
classes is constantly being challenged
by a new generation of uprising.
As we saw in over the
summer, the most fierce
and the most wonderful multi-racial
uprising that we saw that
challenged the very processes
of differential life-making
and the children's strikes
that we saw last year against
ecological devastation.
So I want to end on that
note and look towards
those kinds of horizons as are
possibilities for the future.
- And we thank you for that.
And for the talk,
a great round of applause.
- Thank you so much.
- Would be happening.
Thanks again for coming.